[Music]
welcome to
scene at the academy i'm michael ordonia
of the los angeles times
and i'm delighted to be speaking today
with the directors and producers of
cherry from apple tv plus
cherries about a nice young man who
falls in love
goes to war comes back with crippling
ptsd
and along with his wife becomes a
hardcore opioid addict the two of them
then turned
bankrobin to fund their addiction
here we have the filmmakers anthony
and joe russo welcome gentlemen thank
you michael
thank you good to see you
yeah it's good to see you guys again um
there's a lot to talk about with this
film because
of some of the extreme cinematic
approaches you use in it
the uh the character goes through a lot
of
serious changes and i think that you
guys
um tried to convey that cinematically
which might come as a surprise to people
who only know your work from marvel
and i think that a lot of people
watching this even people in the film
community only know your
massive marvel movies or they might know
you from
arrested development or community but
your roots are actually in the
independent film world from far outside
hollywood right
that's right we were we started making
movies in cleveland ohio in the mid 90s
uh we were inspired by the sundance
craze where
it seemed like everyone was trying to
pick up a 16 millimeter camera
and shoot a movie and gain some
notoriety for it
and it was a craze that was inspired by
um
stephen soderbergh uh and interestingly
enough
you know with his movie sexualizing
videotape that sundance in either 88 or
89.
interestingly enough it was sodeberg who
then discovered us
because of a micro budget movie we made
in cleveland in the 90s so
we we did come up through the
independent film scene
well before we turn to the uh the scenes
that we're going to have you break down
for us
uh could you tell us something about the
the films or filmmakers who
influenced your your cinematic
uh aesthetic
wow you know joe and i grew up
real cinephiles and we were both
fans of commercial hollywood filmmaking
and we were very fortunate to grow up
near a wonderful place called the
cleveland cinema tech
which had an amazing program of arts
cinema and world cinema
and we devoured everything growing up so
our our influences are pretty wide
ranging
but i would say in relationship to
cherry
you know we were very fond of the french
new wave and
most specifically true foe and i think
you know his sort of spirit and
adventurous
uh cinematic style and
sort of uh level of self-awareness uh
may
you know maybe me in some ways speak
most directly to cherry
yeah i think look this movie is
spans a 15-year life cycle in the life
of the lead character
and this character goes through some
very intense
experiences over the course of that life
cycle inclusive of which is falling in
love with the girl of his dreams
making the decision to enlist in the
army during the iraq war goes to basic
training goes to war
suffers from ptsd as you mentioned uh
starts self-medicating with street drugs
becomes an addict
it becomes a criminal to support the
addict and then ultimately gets
incarcerated for
over a decade uh as a penance for
um becoming a criminal so the movie
spans an intense amount of experience
for the character
and we wanted to break the movie up into
six distinct
chapters where each chapter has a
different tone
it's executed in a different style has
different color palette different lenses
different performance style and this
particular scene is from chapter two
when cherry goes to basic training and
it was all shot
with a single wide lens the same lens
it's a distortive lens we actively
limit the aspect ratio of the film at
this point
so if you've been watching the movie up
till this point it's in a different
aspect ratio
and at the start of basic training the
aspect ratio actually collapses
because we want to show the world
collapsing in on the character and it's
starting to confine
who he is and it's going to dictate uh
where his life goes from here
for us it was sort of a blast of cold
water in cherry's face
in terms of not understanding what he
was going through it's a very aggressive
environment
he finds himself dropped into here's a
there's a young man who wanted to
go to the war because he felt like he
could possibly
do some good there wanted to become a
medic and he finds himself in basic
training
which is sort of a hyper aggressive
environment
where it's kind of hard to track for him
to track the actual training
and then again staying locked to the
same lens throughout the entire
experience
again was sort of speaking to the sense
of of monotony and the sense of like a
very
being being locked into a very rigid
um sort of uh
a rigid unforgiving situation
uh so that we were sort of chasing all
that in terms of uh
our choices in this sequence and in the
scene
well how does that contrast with the
very next scene when he
actually experiences combat what was
what was your approach to
him seeing what really happens in war
the way the chapters break down in the
movie the first chapter is him falling
in love
and it's him in college meeting the girl
of his dreams there's a magical realism
to it
there's a lot of soft focus everything
falls off the world is very much about
he and this girl that he's fallen for
and the movie at its heart
is a tragic modern love story it's about
two people
this boy and this girl who make
decisions that they don't have life
experience to make
that unfortunately sends them on a
journey into hell
and back again the second chapter as we
talked about
uh is absurdism that is basic training
it's about disconnecting
uh while trying to maintain his humanity
the third chapter is he goes to war
and that absurdism translates into war
but a horror starts to creep in
because there are elements that you know
don't exist in basic training there's
death
there's there's um tragedy and there's
things that his brain cannot process it
you were wide awake when you got on the
ground outside the wire for the first
time
you're expected to get shot at any
moment
even if you were in a spot where you
couldn't see anyone for miles you were
nevertheless sure that there was a [ __ ]
out there who'd been waiting all day
just to shoot you
great great raven base this is quebec
romeo foxtrot
we are seven minutes out on route to
take over
number one [ __ ] it up
i'll get the cure
let's grab your [ __ ] let's go go
[Applause]
he's thrust into existential crisis in
this war that he doesn't know how to
deal with again he's too young to
process these things
so the fourth chapter is about his ptsd
and that's what this next scene is from
and that chapter is about psychological
war it's about being trapped
in your own mind being trapped with
these images that he can't escape
and it's very tense it's the most
disturbing part of the movie
certainly the most disturbing for me to
watch as a filmmaker
and i think that um you know he starts
to
you'll notice in the scene that we're
using very extreme
uh framing choices we're pushing him off
left or off right in the frame
he's starting to uh there and the frames
are incongruous it's not
symmetrical opposite uh editing it is uh
it's a unique frame on him and then a
unique frame on the person that he's
talking to
he's starting to use alcohol and drugs
to numb
uh his ptsd and so the whole scene plays
from this um
this this distorted uh point of view and
the way that he's feeling about
the world he's now becoming hyper
aggressive he gets in a shouting match
with some
patrons down below because you know
they're not dressed up for the theater
so he starts to do things that are
illogical and emotional
because he can't control that that
subconscious aspect of himself
hey thank you for thinking to do this
why are we the only ones dressed up
doesn't matter didn't notice
all these middle-aged people with money
for christ's sakes and they can't even
be bothered to wear a jacket to the
[ __ ] theater
yeah i'm talking to you what's your
problem dude what's your problem my
problem is the fact you didn't even have
the decency to take off your ll bean
before you came from the [ __ ] golf
life
we're not going anywhere i would really
like to leave
it's all right man there's nothing to
[ __ ] look at this guy's just an
[ __ ]
take this llp and shove it up your
[ __ ] ass
that was one of the things that struck
us most about the novel
and why we wanted to sort of translate
this story
to film is that at the heart of this
character
is a very relatable human is the very
relatable human experience of feeling
disconnected and isolated
and that can you know and and there's a
the way that it's conveyed in the novel
is largely through a running
sort of inner monologue that the
character is having
as he's going through a variety of of
extreme life experiences sometimes
extreme and sometimes
normal life experiences um and you know
that was really what we wanted to
capture
is this sense of isolation the sense of
disconnect
and figure out how do we connect the
chariot how do we how do we empathize
with chair what cherry's going through
because he makes some complicated
decisions as we all do everybody makes
some bad choices in life
um but how do you
stay with a character stay with another
human being
despite the fact or while they're making
bad choices and how do you continue to
have that empathy for them through a
complicated situation
that was a lot of our experience in
terms of how we structured structured
the story
and the narrative it's a good definitely
a good contrast
between basic training and ptsd
but also because we want to illustrate
the journey that this movie goes on
one of the things that's so critical to
us about the subject matter of this film
is very personal to us we have friends
and
and family who have died because of the
opioid crisis and we have others
who are still struggling with their
sobriety
and this is you know we're living in a
world where a drug was scientifically
manufactured
to make people addicted to it in order
to make money
uh and we're seeing the you know and
it's it's ravaging society this is the
most deadly year
of the epidemic which is coinciding with
with the pandemic so
it's important for us uh to try to
generate
empathy around this issue we feel like
there is a uh
a lack of empathy in the world today and
it's a progressive
problem uh it's progressing it's it has
to do with the internet and technology
social media distancing we are
dehumanizing and otherizing one another
uh and and we feel strongly as as
individuals and as filmmakers that
this crisis needs to be treated with
empathy in order for us to overcome it
uh you know incarceration is not the
answer for
um uh for for every aspect
of this drug crisis that we're in the
middle of and that if we don't
introduce empathy um and we can see this
at all levels
of this country at the moment uh we're
going to be in a lot of trouble in a
couple of years
well gentlemen um i'm afraid we're out
of time but thank you so much for giving
us more insight into those scenes and
into your film
it's certainly a a very interesting
approach and especially when
knowing that it's in the the town you
came from
and your personal connection stories it
uh it lends a lot of dimension
to what you put on the screen so thank
you very much for your time for joining
us at steam at the academy
um anthony russo and joe russo thank you
thank you so much
you